todo el motor en marcha
despegue tenemos un despegue 32 minutos
después de la hora despegamos en el
apolo 11 un pequeño paso para el hombre
un gran salto para la humanidad
cuál crees tú que es la forma de la
tierra
no lo creo estoy seguro de que es un
globo la tierra es plana es como si
tuviéramos una imagen de la realidad que
es una gran pieza de rompecabezas y
luego una de esas piezas no encaja
siempre estoy abierto a tener una
discusión con alguien que tiene una
creencia errónea como ésta cambiarías tu
opinión al respecto no lo creo hay mucha
mucha evidencia nadie quiere creer en la
tierra plana pero si me muestras
evidencias irrefutables
puede que me retracté no hay duda de eso
qué esperas obtener de una discusión con
los demás compañeros creo que los haré
pedazos
[Música]
soy jim under down director ejecutivo
del center for inquiry west en los
ángeles y presidente del
cf investigation group soy spencer marks
uno de los miembros principales del cf
investigations group defensor de la
ciencia me llamo al jury soy físico
teórico y trabajo en la universidad de
irwin soy wendel walton soy director de
aprendizaje de una empresa joven soy
cell y louis graduada en west point
pensador a crítica y paracaidista me
llamo dan glickman trabajo como el water
band en la industria de filtración de
agua potable y un amante de la verdad
pueden ponerse los que piensan que la
tierra es plana a la izquierda y los
científicos a la derecha
[Aplausos]
solo den un paso al frente si creen que
es cierto creo que la tierra fue creada
por una fuerza suprema
he sido cristiano durante 30 años para
mí la biblia es un libro basado en una
tierra plana hay que tomarlo
literalmente por ejemplo en isaías
cuando habla de como la tierra es como
un sello de cera de arcilla con los
bordes hacia arriba no es una historia
elegante eso es un símil eso es así
exacto estoy de acuerdo y luego isaías
habla sobre eso también soy cristiana él
reina sobre el círculo de la tierra y
hay diferencia entre un círculo y una
pelota sí exactamente si nos fijamos en
el hebreo original significa disco hay
más de 200 escrituras en la biblia que
apuntan a una tierra plana
miren esta noción de que se necesita
dios o algún poder superior para crear
la tierra o el universo es muy antigua y
fue inicialmente postulada por personas
de una era pre científica desde entonces
hemos aprendido bastante sobre la
existencia del universo y cuando sucedió
los humanos modernos no tienen la
cosmología ni la física ellos no tienen
su conocimiento del universo de la
biblia o de cualquier texto antiguo es
como el dios de los baches una vez la
gente solía creer que el relámpago era
la ira de dios y que él lanzaba estos
relámpagos pero una vez que entendimos
que era un proceso natural dios se
encogió un poco más porque ahora no
podíamos atribuir esos relámpagos a dios
tuvimos que atribuir eso la ciencia real
y la otra cosa el punto sobre la biblia
específicamente para mí es porque ese
texto en particular es el correcto
eliges creer eso y eso está bien pero
hay tantos otros escritos y tantos otros
libros entonces porque no eran correctos
porque es correcta la vid bueno lo que
encontrarás en muchas de estas
religiones antiguas es que todas son
religiones de tierra plana toda su
cosmología se remonta a ser una tierra
plana con un sistema cerrado así que no
es sólo la biblia la que te enseña esto
son muchos libros religiosos diferentes
hay un problema con esto y es tratar de
explicar
los fenómenos que ocurren en la
naturaleza por los libros sagrados esos
son libros religiosos esos no son libros
de ciencia y es un error inferir o
deducir lecturas científicas de todos
esos libros
mi nombre es wendel soy un pensador
lógico basado en la biblia y también soy
científico yo no empecé y nadie empieza
en la teoría de la tierra plana pero
tenía muchas preguntas así que la verdad
llegué al punto donde tenía que salir y
abrir mis propios ojos a eso así que
fuimos a una observación en el mar de
saltón y las cosas no eran certeras ahí
abajo entonces volvimos probablemente
una docena de veces y te puedo
garantizar que no hay curvatura en la
distancia el internet juega un papel
importante para reforzar mi punto de
vista sobre esta teoría
pues ese es el problema
tenemos la ventaja de la información hoy
que está fuera de los canales 2 4 y 7 y
las pocas redes que son propiedad
corporativa es bastante fácil decir que
youtube no es investigación pero cuando
pasa suficiente tiempo recoges bastante
información y estos paneles grupales de
discusión hemos ido en contra de la
oposición nos hemos opuesto
sorprendentemente la tierra plana es su
peor enemigo así que no es tan fácil
para nosotros llegar a un consenso y
encontramos que el consenso está
orquestado y en realidad no es
científico de ninguna manera mi abuelo
solía decirme cuando era niño que nunca
creyera nada de lo que leía en el
periódico me lo decía ahora con la era
de internet es como cuanto de esta
desinformación estás recibiendo allí y
cuando tienes testigos oculares filmando
algo lo haces para tomar todo para
causar más furor por eso debido a mis
antecedentes en multimedia sabía que
podía ser falsificado modificado por
after effects alterado por photoshop
bien este es el núcleo de la razón por
la que hay tantos creyentes de la tierra
plana y afuera ahora mismo el problema
es que la información de alguien que
decide iniciar un sitio web o producir
un vídeo de youtube no es confiable
cuando tengo dolor de muelas voy al
dentista si mi auto se daña voy al
mecánico cuando tienes preguntas sobre
cosmología debes ir a un astrofísico
debes ir a un físico debes ir a las
personas que han pasado años y años
estudiando estas ideas no unos 6 minutos
de vídeo de youtube hay un porcentaje de
personas que si vieran un vídeo de
youtube que no estuviera dentro de sus
habilidades científicas para refutarlo a
primera vista creería cualquier cosa ahí
afuera una de las cosas que diré es que
la página de la nasa tiene sus propios
documentos en exhibición que podemos
examinar a través de la ley de libertad
de información
estarías de acuerdo en que los
documentos de la nasa puedan ser
investigados y documentados por nosotros
la nasa no prueba que la tierra sea
y deberías escucharlo está encantado de
ver la evidencia de lanza sobre la
tierra problemas de contradicción los
que guardo estás trajeron a todos
estamos familiarizados con la foto de la
elevación de la tierra ella está elevada
sobre la luna es una foto tomada por la
nasa puedes ir allí y descargarla se lo
que estás a punto de presionar pones en
la iluminación correcta puedes ver dónde
está cortada y pegada allí nos muestran
imágenes manipuladas que son claramente
falsas la canica azul es una imagen muy
famosa de 1972 cuando hablas con el
artista de la nasa su nombre es robert
simmons habla de cómo fue creado a
partir de datos y no es una fotografía
en absoluto el área dio las nubes dejame
cambiar añadió la luz del sol fijas en
tu teléfono la mayoría de los teléfonos
tienen esa imagen panorámica cuando
haces eso tomas una serie de fotos y el
teléfono las juntas inteligentemente
refiera cómo fue presentada la preferia
tuvieron una cuando la grasa toma fotos
reales o bien las limpian para el color
o las juntan por lo que es una imagen
grande no significa que son falsa estás
hablando de composiciones
soy lo que llaman un mirador del globo
terráqueo
incluso
podrían meterme en una construcción
virtual si yo mismo no puedo encontrar
las fronteras que forma crees que tiene
la tierra me parece un plano
estacionario opuesto a la inmensidad de
la infinidad del espacio yo encontraría
que es un plano de hielo donde tenemos
un sol localizado y nuestro medio
ambiente prospera allí estas personas en
particular nos han engañado en la
televisión esta es una oportunidad
brillante para discutir hemos sido
reprimidos censurados por los medios de
comunicación principales los medios
alternativos son algo hermoso para mí
veo el otro lado como inculto
voy corriendo
ellos creen que somos los incultos de
seguro piensan que son los más cultos y
están siguiendo
bastante del sistema universitario lo
que llamamos cientifismo muy cierto
obviamente es la creencia en lo que está
escrito donde tendemos a explorar en el
campo con propiedades físicas no teorías
de ningún tipo estamos usando medidas
reales que se calculan no por nuestras
directrices sino por las de la ciencia
tal como la conocemos solo espero que
sean educados en lugar de falsos bueno
eso es otra cosa también porque sabemos
que a gran escala el gobierno ha sido
falso y están presionando una narrativa
así que es difícil para nosotros estoy
seguro de que también has conocido gente
es como acaso no lo has investigado
todavía o eres un cómplice o eres parte
de una campaña de desinformación
yo no creo que ustedes sean incultos
solo creo que están mal educados creo
que el problema con lo que he visto en
la sociedad de la tierra plana es que no
es que estén poco educados pero en lugar
de mirar la evidencia y dejar que la
evidencia a los guías donde está la
conclusión final comienzan con una
conclusión y luego tratan de escoger la
evidencia para apoyar su conclusión pre
dibujada desechan todas las pruebas que
en realidad son contrarias a su sistema
de creencias yo creo que eres tan culto
como como lo es
creo que allí también el currículo
impresionan a de 20 y el pago por ello
también si lo ven más y más
profesionales están llegando a bordo
están empezando a cuestionar su realidad
así que la cosa es que una vez que
empiezas a mirar de verdad y le echas un
vistazo a la evidencia ya no tienes
miedo de defender la verdad donde sea
que te lleve entonces la gente termina
convirtiéndose en defensores de la
tierra plana
qué esperas conseguir con el debate de
hoy espero poder contar nuestro lado de
la historia desde adentro hacia afuera
muchas veces se representa a los
defensores de la tierra plana desde
afuera hacia adentro y quiero compartir
otros datos empíricos que prueban que la
tierra no es lo que han dicho
he cambiado mi opinión a lo largo de
este debate
pues cuando tenía 12 años fui al
campamento espacial y conocí a alan sepa
si quería ser astronauta y ser la
primera mujer en caminar por la luna así
que al principio estaba del otro lado
entre en esto completamente queriendo
que fuera verdad y mi marido me dijo que
vio esta cosa sobre el falso alunizaje y
yo estaba como estás absolutamente loco
es imposible que los alunizajes sean
falsos luego en el 2010 mi esposo fue
asesinado y nunca lo desarrolle hasta
más o menos el 2014 cuando la tierra
plana volvió
disculpen esa voz dentro de mi cabeza
dijo recuerdas los falsos alunizajes
recuerdas cuando llamaron mi atención y
luego empecé a analizarlo críticamente y
yo diría con sólo mirar esa evidencia si
pueden mentir sobre los aterrizajes en
la luna pueden mentir sobre imágenes
satélites y otras cosas y así empecé a
bajar por esa madriguera de estudio así
que esa fue mi influencia ni estas
mentiras se necesitan para hacer a un
mentiroso y ser ridiculizado por ser
inquisitivo es bastante duro para
nosotros yo no diría que he cambiado de
opinión porque mi mente no está
establecida la nasa está diseñada
únicamente para cambiar mi mente desde
su inicio desde su descubrimiento ha
sido un programa de televisión un
programa espacial para vendernos algo
que aún no nos han mostrado me muestras
un globo girando con nubes y una luna
diciendo esta es tu casa creo que así
podría dejar de cuestionar
creo que podría hasta callarme
el momento de sus conversiones es
interesante para mí hace 20 años el
mundo de la tierra plana era diminuto e
insignificante y luego entra el
advenimiento de internet youtube grupos
de discusión en línea todos estos nuevos
lugares disponibles donde se puede
encontrar información sobre todo es
cierto que
la evidencia tal como ustedes la ven no
es evidencia sólida y las fuentes que
utilizan no son fuentes confiables y
repito pero mi problema es que me gustan
ustedes que son muy escépticos pero al
mismo tiempo no son escépticos acerca de
su sistema de creencias eso debería
verse primero que esa es mi base por la
cual yo creo que la tierra es plana les
digo están equivocados no evidencia que
prueba que es plana y puedo probar que
no es una esfera qué clase de engaño
somos engañados deliberadamente por los
medios más la evidencia que nos
mostraremos ver distancias largas si
podemos ver demasiado lejos no
deberíamos ser capaces viven tan al
mundo puedo ver la isla de san clemente
que está a 95 kilómetros de distancia
puedo verlo parada claro podrías ver un
barco en marcha o si hablemos de los
barcos que van sobre la curvatura de la
tierra y me encanta eso así que la
ciencia dice que cuando ve un barco
salir de mi campo de visión va sobre la
curvatura de la tierra correcto pero de
mi cámara y adivinen que puedo verlo de
nuevo entonces está pasando por encima
de la curvatura de la tierra o no eso no
se ve todo el barco la parte inferior
debería durar la parte superior
si la tierra fuese verdaderamente plana
no habría ningún límite y seríamos
capaces de estar en la parte superior
del edificio empire state y mirar hacia
chicago y a sólo 1.600 kilómetros de
distancia ver las luces de chicago por
la noche
atmosférica muy espesa he estudiado
astronomía desde los 10 años tu lógica
está errada es una teoría completamente
errada hagamos un receso luego
debatiremos más puntos interesantes está
bien
una de las grandes cosas que hago es
investigar afirmaciones extraordinarias
como la tierra es plana o todo tipo de
cosas diferentes el planeta tierra es
sin duda un globo terráqueo y no es
plana y esto está bien respaldado por
mucha ciencia el consenso científico es
posible el consenso científico es
posible cuál es la pregunta no entendí
la pregunta y el consenso científico es
posible posible todo es posible es decir
todo es posible tengo un gran problema
con el consenso y la revisión por pares
he pasado mucho tiempo discutiendo con
personas que argumentan del otro lado y
descubrí que el consenso siempre gana me
sorprendió que el grupo con la mayoría
tenga una ventaja increíble
como científicos
terratenientes
médicos
tenemos una desventaja increíble
hablemos de consenso científico por un
segundo nunca obtendrás el 100% de nadie
existe un consenso científico en una
tierra global existe un consenso
científico sobre una evolución muchos
problemas y la palabra teoría no sabes
que una teoría en la ciencia es
extremadamente y los hechos son los
trucos juntas la palabra teoría o sea no
hay conjeturas
por definición es una definición
teoría en la ciencia en la palabra
teoría es el nivel más alto que se puede
dar a algo que está muy bien sustentado
que tal un hecho eso es un hecho no es
un hecho porque tú lo llames uno sabe
por qué sabes por qué porque en la
ciencia siempre hay espacio para mejorar
siempre hay espacio para mejorar para
ajustar y encontrar mejor información
suisse cómo funciona la ciencia se
refina mejor con el tiempo a diferencia
de la teoría de la tierra plana que
nunca se refiere simplemente es lo que
ellas nuevas ideas tienen un acceso
limitado a los
y una exposición limitada hasta que
estemos en los planes de estudios
universitarios y seguiremos apareciendo
sin educación porque eso no es cierto en
la historia de la ciencia tuvimos muchas
ocasiones en las que algunas ideas no
fueron bien recibidas por la sociedad
einstein fue un ejemplo de eso galilea
yo leo fue uno de ellos pero si tu
teoría es auténtica y puede pasar por
esta dificultad del método científico
eventualmente ganará
yo solía creer que la ciencia buscaba la
verdad cierto todos queremos saber cuál
es la verdad la ciencia ha estado
tratando tan duramente de divorciarse de
la idea de un creador cuando la
intención de dios era crear ciencia para
conducirte a él a veces las cosas
parecen sobrenaturales que podemos
explicar más tarde a través de la
ciencia de acuerdo lo entiendo pero hay
otras cosas también que son
sobrenaturales que van más allá de lo
natural que siempre podemos explicar a
través de creer en un creador este es mi
gran problema con el enfoque científico
y el enfoque no científico tienes toda
la razón en la ciencia buscamos la
verdad y esperamos que cada día nos
estemos acercando más y más a la verdad
pero nunca llegaremos allí nunca nunca
pero sé que es verdad para ti no no esto
es ciencia son ustedes que piensan que
tienen la verdad ahora veamos las
evidencias como estaban mencionando ya
tenemos la conclusión encontremos las
evidencias la ciencia no funciona
eso tú te estás refiriendo a jesús en
quien miles de millones de personas no
creen incluyéndome a mí miles de
millones que sí y quién está en lo
correcto claro que puedo decir que
cuando dices que empezamos con la
conclusión y luego tratamos de igualar
todo para que funcione me parece que es
una verdadera hipocresía eso no es
cierto eso es lo que estás haciendo una
suposición de lo que la ciencia hace
mucho entonces hace suposiciones o no
las ciencias exposiciones no me estás
diciendo que no las hace bien
suposiciones basadas en cosas que están
bien sustentadas y aprobadas muy probada
parcialmente demuéstrame cómo aislar y
as la gravedad si la gravedad es una
suposición muestran el método científico
para aislarlos un argumento para parar
vamos a refrescarnos y volvemos luego
[Música]
me gustaría saber
cómo se sienten qué les ha parecido el
debate creo que quiero desarrollar algo
de esto un poco más se siente de alto
nivel pero hay tanto que creo que ni
siquiera hemos tocado la base bueno la
verdad no creo que alguien de ambos
lados se deje convencer por el otro aún
estamos a tiempo todavía hay tiempo para
ti claro no creo que podamos contar
también tengo esperanza pero a mí me
alegra que sea una discusión civilizada
o se pongan los envases a su lado
haremos otra pregunta
te viniste a nuestro lado lo convenció
[Risas]
este es el momento más hermoso del atv
muy bien la nasa es confiable
bueno obviamente cualquier organización
puede estar equivocada con ciertas cosas
y pueden tener individuos que mienten o
engañan o algo así pero como una
organización general
están buscando la verdad si la idea de
que la nasa y el gobierno nos mienten
sobre la forma de la tierra es el colmo
de esas teorías conspirativas para que
eso sea cierto
los literalmente cientos de miles de
personas que en algún momento de los
últimos
50 o 60 años
habrían tenido que ser un poco cómplices
en esto y nadie se ha pronunciado al
respecto es a primera vista
completamente increíble
el soldado no sabe lo que el general
está haciendo hay muchas cosas
sucediendo todo el tiempo eso no sería
tan descabellado alguna vez el gobierno
nos mintió allí está el juego todos
estamos aquí es la verdad
verdad
absolutamente no están mintiendo sobre
nada son completamente transparentes
lo siento esto es una falacia no es así
yo creo que estoy seguro que es adelante
estaban hablando de un gobierno ahora
están hablando de una agencia de viento
pero esta agencia es examinada por miles
y miles de científicos de todo el mundo
y estás tratando con gente inteligente
créeme estás tratando con nolan y no lo
niego así que es muy difícil hacer eso
una o dos veces tal vez pero no todo el
tiempo levanta la mano si crees que
fuimos a la luna
cuál es la prueba cientos y cientos de
kilos de rocas lunares y polvo y los
hemos distribuido libremente entre
científicos de todo el mundo y ninguno
de esos geólogos ha dicho que esto han
demostrado y
así no hay que ir a la luna para
conseguir rocas lunares las fotografías
de la fuerza aérea de los eeuu
anteriores a 1958 muestran una tierra
plana solo la nasa nos muestra un globo
no te mentiría la la otra prueba que
tenemos entiendo este amigo el yo no lo
otro reflector láser que tenemos en la
luz y lo estoy pensando ahora lo usamos
hasta hoy es ir a ver es encontrar hasta
la más mínima medida de lo lejos está la
del aterrizar sabemos que está ahí claro
que no me pregunta para ustedes es por
qué porque toda esta gente honesta y
trabajadora
perpetuaría este fraude masivo porque
ellos harían eso qué beneficio obtienen
bien el beneficio de esto es que ganan
52 millones de dólares al día si buscan
dinero y por eso es que debatimos estas
cosas pero no empezó así la nasa no fue
fundada para probar que la tierra era un
globo eso no tiene nada que ver con la
forma en que fue encima si estás seguro
y positivo y verdad sí
alguien debe ser una voz para la razón y
alguien tiene que ser una voz para la
verdad sería una fantasía creer que
cambiaría la mente de cualquiera de los
otros tres sin embargo si hay alguien
sentado en la pantalla y esta es la
primera introducción a este debate tal
vez van a escuchar la voz razonable y
decir eso tiene más sentido que ver la
tierra en forma de pizza
me pongo
en el lugar de mis compañeros
solía creer en la tierra como una esfera
todo lo que dicen ustedes es
completamente lo que antes solía aceptar
así que entiendo completamente de dónde
vienen para mí creo que que la manera
correcta de hacer cualquier tipo de
investigación o de examinar las cosas es
poniéndote literalmente en esa
mentalidad de la otra persona así que
hago eso no estoy de acuerdo con su
posición pero entiendo completamente
desde su perspectiva lo que están
diciendo
el problema que tengo al entender tu
perspectiva es que en el mundo moderno a
menos que vivas en una cueva en alguna
parte tienes que creer en la ciencia
implícitamente conocí a una joven que
decía no confío en nada de lo que hace
la ciencia y eso es un problema porque
los seres humanos no pueden replicar
todo el cuerpo de la ciencia por cada
generación en algún punto tienes que
confiar en lo que ya ha sido descubierto
y probado y pasar a lo siguiente de lo
contrario no avanzaremos en nada es
decir cuando giras la llave del
encendido de tu auto esperas que
encienda para conducir no está allá y no
está allá porque la ciencia te puso en
esa posición así que es realmente
difícil entender cómo la gente sabe en
sus corazones que la ciencia logra cosas
maravillosas y luego abandonan el barco
cuando se trata de este otro tema no
sacamos conclusiones entendemos los
mecanismos que hicieron que la auto
funcione no hay teorías
y no hay conclusiones en disputa
involucrados allí no es una buena
analogía puedo admitir un gran
compromiso que tenemos que experimentar
al estar en contra de la gente del
gremio y es que tenemos que sentarnos en
un grupo y decidir si podemos o no
darnos el lujo de tener una opinión y
eso es difícil
estoy de acuerdo con ustedes porque
somos lo mismo quiero decir creo que los
escépticos pasan por esto y los ateos
pasan por esto no creo en dios cuando
estoy con gente religiosa me arriesgo
socialmente cuando les digo que soy ateo
así que se necesita un poco de valor
para seguir tus creencias y aprecio eso
pero también creo que he hecho varias
investigaciones hasta este punto y no es
algo en lo que elija creer es algo en lo
que tengo que creer basado en la
evidencia lo que aprendo de ustedes es
que debes creer entonces cómo es que
creen en dios o en jesús no han visto a
ningún visto pero es cierto
exactamente así que estamos buscando
evidencia hay muchas muchas otras
evidencias
sé que la tierra no es plana mi punto es
que estos experimentos muestran
claramente que la tierra es un globo y
no necesita salir del globo para
conclusión globo es una alegoría y haz
la evidencia sitio solo solo miras para
ver algo entonces discuto tu sistema de
creencias en dios y jesús o jehová o
buda o zaratustra o cualquiera sigues
volviendo a la religión como
evidencia evidencia de
todo pero esa no es la única razón por
la que sé cuál es la forma de la tierra
no y tú mantienes tu postura no es una
falacia es una falacia estoy seguro que
no lo hago que es inseguro ok ok ok
soy un físico teórico lo que estoy
haciendo es la combinación de la teoría
de cuerdas y la cosmología así que
tratamos de entender lo que pasó durante
el big bang' después del big bang o
incluso antes del big band que esperas
obtener de la discusión de hoy espero
poder ser especial para la generación
joven para convencerlos de que primero
deben pensar críticamente y no creer
nada no deberían dar nada por sentado
miren las evidencias y examinen las
desechen las afirmaciones
eso es importante si no están basadas en
evidencias reales
la ciencia no es porque estén aquí pero
cuando se habla de ciencia espacial es
muy difícil de entender para la mayoría
de la gente y está diseñado de esa
manera y así de muchas maneras
esconderse detrás de la ciencia espacial
es similar a la religión si miras a la
iglesia católica en los viejos tiempos
solo nosotros podíamos interpretar la
biblia tienes que escuchar lo que
decimos así que de muchas maneras
estamos obteniendo la misma noción de la
ciencia que dice solo nosotros podemos
interpretar lo que son estos números
pero entonces cuando realmente vamos y
probamos algunas de sus ecuaciones y no
funcionan esto nos lleva a la duda
podemos ir y probarlo nosotros mismos
absolutamente yo diría que una gran
ventaja de la ciencia es su
previsibilidad
supongamos por un segundo por un segundo
que su modelo este modelo de tierra
plana es correcto no sé qué es lo que
nos engancha a él que predice para
nosotros así que mi pregunta para
ustedes sería la próxima vez tráiganme
algo de su teoría
de lo que puedan predecir algo que el
modelo de la tierra no pueda predecir
entonces cambiaría de opinión yo diría
que no creas en nada de lo que digo
tienes que hacer tu propia investigación
y creo que lo que encontrarás es que
verás que una pieza del rompecabezas no
encaja y la única manera es si pones tus
ojos en él no culpo a la gente por ser
escéptica soy escéptico sobre muchas
cosas diferentes aplaudo ese instinto en
ustedes pero tienen que ir más allá de
no creer en algo haz las preguntas
difíciles pregunta qué califica a un
youtuber o un autor de libros en
cualquier otro lugar que está recibiendo
esta información lo que los califica
para hacer comentarios de amplio alcance
sobre la forma de la tierra mira
cualquiera que pueda anular a einstein o
alguna teoría importante va a ser
finalmente escrito en los salones de la
ciencia por el resto de sus vidas pero
tienen que llegar a los bienes tienen
que mostrar
una buena evidencia basada en la ciencia
de que lo que dicen es cierto soportando
la prueba del tiempo y la revisión por
pares y los rigores del método
científico
fue un placer muchas gracias debemos
darnos a conocer
gracias mucho gusto
jubilee vive intensamente